[Music]
first up james forsythe writes in this
week's cover piece that boris johnson is
looking to get the gang back together
for one last brexit bust-up the prime
minister he says wants to tear up parts
of the brexit deal because of problems
betrayed between northern ireland and
the republic of ireland
and he may be willing to throw away the
whole agreement to do it where's this
going and how serious might the fallout
be
james our political editor joins me now
alongside lord frost the former brexit
minister
james
in your cover piece this week you write
about a plan the government has when it
comes to the korean speech next week to
reopen the brexit debate can you tell us
more
yeah so in the queen's speech next week
the government will talk about the
importance of protecting the good friday
agreement
in its entirety
and what this is code for is a warning
to the eu that the uk is ultimately
prepared to legislate to override parts
of the northern ireland protocol to
protect the good friday agreement now
the government's argument is that there
are three strands for a good friday
agreement
and all three of them are in trouble
right now uh
the dup pulled out of the devolved power
sharing executive in february and have
been very clear but they won't go back
into it until their concerns about the
protocol have been addressed
there is no north-south ministerial
corporation at the moment and the dep's
whole issue with the protocol is that
they think that it it hinders east
east-west ties and so the government
will say that it is prepared to do this
ministers are increasingly convinced
that this would be legal under
international law because they argue
that they are they are merely moving to
protect the pre-existing international
agreement good friday
and so that gives them legal cover to do
what they want now i mean the big
question here is whether it ever comes
to legislation or not uh this isn't the
first time that boris johnson has tried
to use domestic legislation to shift the
eu's negotiating position think back to
the internal market bill and i think
what the uk government is saying is to
the eu kind of
you've got one last chance to come to
the table and move beyond the kind of
very technical negotiation about the
protocol to a more
uh a broader one about how it should
work and if you won't do that the uk is
prepared to take matters into its own
hands
david you obviously led on this and as
well as being the lead brexit negotiator
uh were in charge of the protocol before
leaving government what did you make on
uh hearing about this plan was that
something you're aware of uh was in the
making before you left
so i think it is a sensible plan i think
the protocol
it was a delicately balanced instrument
uh created in very difficult
circumstances it hasn't had good
handling
since uh we left the the eu and the
transition period
i think the good friday agreement is on
life support and now really and i don't
see that the government has got some
other any other choice other than to
to act itself now
i agree with james that i think it would
still be much better if we could agree
a revised set of arrangements with the
eu and i i still find it slightly
surprising the eu won't do this when it
seems very obviously in the wider
interest so i think it's right if that's
the government's plan to give it another
go but they can't take very long about
it it really does have to be a kind of
ultimatum and
if not i think the government's gone no
other choice than than to act uh it's
obvious that protocol has got to change
or be replaced the only question is how
we get there
james why are the talks going nowhere
you say in your cover piece that this
truss has brought a new approach to it
in terms of tone
um
perhaps being uh softer in her approach
and less confrontational than her
predecessor who is also on in this
conversation and but yet that doesn't
seem to be bringing any new response
from the eu whatsoever
yes
as one uh figure on the british side
said to me after liz trust took over the
atmosphere in the room keeps getting
better but we're not getting any further
forward i i think the problem is that
the the eu
the protocol was meant to do two things
it was meant to protect the good friday
agreement and the integrity of a single
market
i think frankly the problem is that for
most eu member states the protecting the
integrity of a single market
uh is is the more important of those two
priorities and that leads to some very
legalistic approaches to enforcement
that i i think are that go beyond what
is required for example we haven't had
the protocol fully enforced in the last
two years there have been grace periods
i don't think you could say that the
integrity of a single market has been
destroyed by those great spirits so why
not make them permanent that would be i
think a decent basis on which to start
a a new discussion
uh and i i think the the the other issue
is
what the eu worries about is not the
situation now where uk and eu
regulations are still pretty much
aligned but what happens in 10 20 years
time when there's been more divergence
you know could this uh this open border
on the island of ireland become a kind
of back door into a single market i
personally think that this risk has been
exaggerated as you've seen during the
grace periods you know we haven't seen
you know uh lots of goods
flowing into uh into the republic from
the north as you know
as contraband that that's not the case i
also think you look at things like for
example the fact that if the government
decided to remove that from uh domestic
energy bills you know that couldn't
apply in northern ireland because of the
protocol it's hard to think that
allowing people's home heating bills to
not have sales tax on them is a in
northern ireland is a threat to the
integrity of a single market dave what
do you make of liz trust's performance
so far
so i think she's done a good job i think
she's you know she's picked it up and
and basically pushed the same things
that i was pushing as far as i can see
and
obviously her styles been a bit
different to mine but um
in the end negotiations are not about
style or warm feelings they're about
interests and you have to be absolutely
clear about what your interests are
and be clear about what will work for
you and what won't and
the the brutal reality is that the eu
have never put anything on the table
that adequately responds to what we put
on the table as a reform proposal last
year they've tinkered around the edges
they've never really grappled with the
the complexity of the problems that have
now emerged and and everyone can can see
that and that's one of the reasons why
we're in the the current position
of course they can say what we have we
hold you agreed this stick to it but you
have to look at the real world and the
real world is that things are
deteriorating fast and
unfortunately the eu is not generally a
nimble negotiator they tend to take
positions and stick to it and that's
that's what we've seen that has got to
change and um
it is very difficult to push the eu into
changing positions
one of the things that you often have to
do is raise the stakes and
perhaps this is what uh the government
is trying to do with these latest
proposals
now we know the eu position is
effectively to say well it's you guys
who agree to this you signed this and we
don't want to retrospectively change
something which both sides agreed to so
james if if we go along with this idea
that he will not budge
and the government go through this plan
what can we expect in terms of the next
steps and potential retaliation
so i think the eu's plan is is is to say
very little after the queen's speech uh
i mean the eu's view is that you know
words in the queen's speech don't
necessarily amount to action and also
there is a view on the on the eu side
that you know that boris johnson would
like a fight with the eu right now
because of his domestic political
situation and so they're not going to
give him one
i think things change if the bill is
actually introduced into parliament i
think at that point the eu will
unfreeze the legal proceedings against
the uk for not having
enforced the protocol
and i also think it will be made clear
that the uk will not be allowed to join
horizon the eu scientific research
program
i think if the bill was to then proceed
through parliament and become law
then i think the eu would uh you know eu
side want to say that their nuclear
option of directly targeting british
products you know tariffs on on
politically sensitive goods and the like
you know that would come into play now
i think that the question is you know
some on the british side think that in
the current geopolitical circumstances
there will be more voices than
previously kind of urging restraint on
the eu side saying look you know we
don't want to get into a trade war at
this moment in time uh given everything
that it that that is happening
uh on uh on
on in ukraine and that the closeness of
the links at the moment between
the uk and uh the eastern european
countries and the bolts david do you
think we could be heading to a
full-blown trade war
well i i mean just for a moment on the
domestic politics of this i think that
there obviously is a brexit coalition
that has supported boris johnson taking
him to this place pushed through brexit
and so on within
the parliamentary party and beyond i i
don't think you can
necessarily extrapolate from that and
say that
boris johnson welcomes a massive
argument with the eu with all the risks
that go with it
particularly when it's over northern
ireland i think it's something that he
feels he has to do
we're pushed into a position where
there's there's no real alternative and
fundamentals like the sovereignty of the
the country are at stake i i don't think
it's
um a political tactic i think it's it's
sort of something that's that's
fundamentally important so
i i do think that needs to be kept in in
mind as well and
one of the things the eu have often done
is is misinterpret as political tactics
things which are actually fundamental to
the world view and and things that we
want to get done
on the question of retaliation is
obviously possible um i think it would
be
uh uh extraordinary if the eu were to
retaliate in a major way in uh
in the trade area while current events
are going on i think it would be a
massive weakening of of of the west
generally and for that reason i don't
think that they're going to i think we
probably will see some measures if if
the government pushes this through but
but honestly i i wonder whether the
heart is going to be there in every
member state to to do this and and push
through when britain is such a leading
player in the the coalition and in a
conflict that let's face it could go on
for some time yet
now james david just touched on the
political implications and obviously in
the case that this is not just uh you
know boris johnson doing it for his own
political safety but could you perhaps
explain to viewers why um there could be
some self-interest here um in terms of
what it means for boris johnson's
position i mean we're talking on
thursday ahead of the local election
results but given partygate and local
elections so you go for everyone expects
the prime minister to be in for a bumpy
few weeks so is the idea that this could
play to his right flank look there are
certainly brexitory mpus who are
frustrated with boris johnson but they
stay their hand against him because they
say look we don't think that any of his
potential successors
would be prepared to see this issue
through to take the risks that are
involved in this in this kind of
brinksmanship so i i think there is that
there is there is uh i'm not saying it
is the driving factor but there there is
clearly an element of domestic uh
politics in domestic party politics
party management
involved here too
i think the biggest thing is that
it is very hard to see if not impossible
how you can get the power sharing
executive in northern ireland up and
running without changes to the protocol
um but i think that i think i think that
you can see though that boris johnson
politically has always been at his
strongest when he has managed to kind of
rally the forces of leave to him both
within and without the tory party and
just on that james then i'll come to
david on this uh before we talk about
the legality and um those who will be
friends to the uk and those and those
who are not um if the government goes
ahead do you think that this would rally
uh brexit voters um you know not just
brexit mps because ultimately if it does
end up in this worst-case scenario where
you have to go ahead the eu retaliates
and you start to see significant uh
disruption to trade um lots of people
could start to think well brexit
actually isn't done despite the prime
minister telling us it was and it was
going to be
yeah i think this is the biggest risk i
mean the two two big risks for boris
johnson first of all um frankly uh
voters in britain tend not to care that
much about northern ireland look at how
little discussion there was of the
protocol during the 2019 general
election campaign for example
i mean the second risk is that in 2019
the tories stood on you know stop the
arguing get brexit done people were fed
up with hearing about it they wanted it
over with done finished uh i think it
would be politically risky to turn
around to people and say actually that
thing we told you was done isn't done
because we've still got this outstanding
issue to deal with i mean that there are
clear political risks in that david do
you agree with that i mean of course you
were a key player in um getting boris
johnson to the point where he could
promise brexit would be done
i mean there obviously are risks you
know if there's serious retaliation you
know who knows but um there are also
opportunities and i think you know boris
is at his strongest not only when he's
talking about brexit but when he's
articulating conservative principles
that the party believes in and if you
know the integrity of the nation state
the you know the integrity of the nation
on the international sphere uh the right
set rules in your own country are not
fundamental conservative principles and
i don't know what is so i think there is
an appeal to this and rightly so
uh that
kind of counterbalances the risk of of
retaliation i think a lot depends on how
it is done the care the strategic
thinking the ability to manage through
what will be a a complex period and of
course a lot depends on what else is
going on at the time
now if we're looking at the wider
geopolitics of this um ultimately james
and because the uk has been talking such
a long time about potentially triggering
article 16 shaking up the protocol
those on the eu side like to say they've
had plenty of time to get their ducks in
a row and to speak to their allies and
one key player here is america if the uk
were to push ahead of this plan do you
think there would be a robust response
from the white house
i i think the americans would be
irritated with the british if the
british pressed ahead with this uh i
think on on two grounds one uh there is
obviously a lot of congressional opinion
in the us that uh view you know
that shares the british view but the
good friday agreement is more important
than the protocol but the problem for
the uk
is you know they're basically inclined
to defer to dublin on whether the good
friday agreement is being honored or not
and dublin's view of what the good
friday agreement and the and its
relationship to the protocol is
radically different from from london's
to put it mildly i think the second
point is
the white house worries about the
broader unity of the west and when you
speak to uh us figures one of the one of
the concerns that they express about
brexit is that the eu in the uk are
going to become like japan and south
korea two u.s allies who fall out at the
drop of a hat and they have to spend
huge amounts of time managing the
relationship and i think if the uk and
the eu were to start falling out again
over the protocol and
i think the white house would consider
that the uk by being the ones who were
choosing to act were were the
instigators of this there would be a lot
of irritation that you know at this
moment when the us is trying to uh to
ensure western unity you know the eu and
the uk to two vital parts of the west
are having this argument which is
distracting from that
david do you think there could also be
an idea building when it comes to the
perception of the uk on the world stage
that the uk doesn't follow law it breaks
international law
or do you think that would be misguided
i i don't think there's any serious risk
of that i think anyone who looks at the
question can see that the protocol is a
very unusual uh beast created in in very
specific circumstances arguably we
weren't sovereign fully well we weren't
suffering fully when we when we agreed
it we were under all sorts of pressures
i think it
um an attempt to redo the protocol or
put in place a better balance i don't
think tells you anything about the the
uk attitude to international law more
broadly we've always been a strong
supporter of the the international
rules-based system of international
institutions and i i don't see that's
that's going to change i dare say the
americans will be a bit irritated if the
government goes down this road um
that's life sometimes things the
americans do irritate us sometimes
things the europeans do do irritate us
but i think that there is a wider um
picture here that that has to be managed
i think that japan south korea and algae
only takes so far um the
the difficulty that we have in uk eu
relationships is the protocol if we can
solve the protocol then there's
absolutely no reason why this
relationship can't be a lot better and
the last few months have shown the
potentialities and that's why it is so
frustrating that we can't we can't move
on but simply acquiescence in the status
quo isn't enough we need to fix it and
fix it better
now i want to move on briefly to
domestic politics before we end this
discussion which is first james just
briefly to viewers what is the time
scale then in terms of we expect in the
queen's speech next week um if the
government were to you know decide to
act on this um what are we looking at so
i think we'll get words in the queen's
speech about protecting the good friday
agreement in its entirety
i think there will then be kind of
one last uh uk attempt to kind of get a
negotiation going i think if that
doesn't
bear fruit then i think you'll see the
uk government saying that it is prepared
to legislate and then introducing a bill
and but i think all the time trying to
trying to say look you know this bill is
making it possible for the dup to have
talks about going back into the power
sharing executive and also keep saying
to the eu we are prepared to to to to
talk to you and we'd rather do this by
negotiation than legislation i think one
of the really big questions is
how does that how does the house of
lords respond to this bill and i think
that talking to uh to peers there are
two key tests first of all
how does it pass the commons if it
passes the commons with uh pretty much
unanimous conservative support the lords
will be more inclined to defer to the
elected house if there is a sizable tory
rebellion over it they will be less so
the second is what does the lords think
about whether this is legal under
international law um
and i think this is going to become a
very big argument
do people accept the uk government
argument that this is what i think will
be the uk government argument which is
this will be legal this is legal because
the uk is moving to protect the
pre-existing international agreement
rather than
just unilaterally ripping up an
agreement because it chooses to they
will argue that they are doing so to
protect a pre-existing agreement that
has precedence
if that argument convinces the lords
then i think the bill could well get
through the laws if it doesn't and the
government ends up having to parliament
act it
that is going to add at least a year to
the process and i think that becomes
much more um
risky for the government because it a
takes the bill much closer up to the
next general election
and also you know there is a there is a
greater chance that uh the eu has more
time to uh create a common position and
there's also a chance that the
geopolitical environment could change
again and the eu could feel much more
comfortable threatening to kind of rip
up the entire tca
now we are speaking on thursday and
effectively we won't know much about the
local election results until early
tomorrow morning and so we are limited
in what we can say but um just a few
brief questions i first wanted to say
james
is this now a referendum in boris
johnson's leadership or has it become
more complicated what's the mood amongst
tory mps
so i i think that the these elections
are sufficiently patchy in england and
particularly in in tory hill parts of
england
that it isn't going to tell us that much
about the wider domestic political scene
i i also think that the tories have done
a very good job of getting their
expectation management in early if you
talk to tory mps this idea that kind of
eight the loss of 800 seats would be par
as got into the bloodstream
while as if you look at some of the
election and analysis from stephen
fischer of oxford university he thinks a
loss of around you know uh 200 odd 250
odd seats would much be much more like
par so you could have a situation where
the tory party has a very bad night but
but it is not quite as bad as tory mps
think and so they are they are more
relaxed my instinct we should say that
we're saying this without knowing the
results is that what these results are
going to do is to
further the divines that are existing
within the tory parliamentary party
i suspect in the next few weeks that
anyone who's got the lib dems in second
place in their seat is going to be more
worried about boris johnson continuing
as leader while people who've got us
northern or midland seat with labour in
second place will be less concerned
about that and i think that one of the
one of boris johnson's advantages is
that it is hard to see the candidates
replace him who appeals to both flanks
of the new tory electoral coalition and
i think that that that i think so i
think we are probably in for a lot yeah
this isn't going to break the stasis in
the tory party and
david you've been critical in the past
about the direction of this government i
wondered in recent weeks we have seen a
new number 10 team brought in new
advisors to the prime minister uh an
attempt i think to to move to the right
on various issues such as rwanda um
are you seeing an improvement
so i think the the ship has been
steadied a bit with the new team and you
know a little bit of
red meat i i
used an analogy when i was writing in
something a few weeks ago being like the
mary rose still a bit top-heavy and
still a bit vulnerable sudden maneuvers
and i think that's that's still true i
think
we
we need to see a bit more conservative
philosophy uh over the next few months
and years if we are to recover from
the midterm blues and you know i've said
what i've said on tax cuts on energy
policy and much precise and i think we
need to just get a bit closer to the
natural supporters on this and some of
these problems will start to disappear
and just finally david given we have you
here i can't help but resist to ask um
there are rumors of banned reports that
uh you could be lined up for the vacant
seat left by neil parish here to quit
the comments um could you be tempted
with a route to being an mp
well i thought i thought you might ask
her um look i only just left government
and i left it you know because i didn't
agree with with various things that are
that are being done and that's that's
still true there's a lot of speculation
around but i haven't really got anything
to say on this subject at the moment and
when i do um i'm sure the spectator will
be the first to know
okay well we'll read books
thank you david thank you james
[Music]
you